Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from a few
more people we do calls via discord, you can
find The David Pakman Show discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's in this next tranche of calls, let's
go to Alexander the Texan.
Alexander, you were on the air.
Speaker 5: Hi, David, I hope you're doing
well.
Thank you.
So I just wanted to get your take on something,
though, I'm seeing with a lot of what I would
call the American bad leftist and a lot of
the general right wing do specific stories
that they ran really hard on, one of which
being.
Allegations of perjury against Anthony Fauci
that The Intercept wrote about, the other
of which being excuse me, the current stories
about Hunter Biden, among more, the common
sense left wing channels.
I would go as far as to say it seems like
like this story is being ignored.
I would just like to hear your thoughts on
this, please, sir.
Speaker 1: Yes.
So I'll go backwards.
I mean, with the Hunter Biden stuff, I just
don't really get what the story would be for
me.
So when I see the you know, I follow the right
wing headlines and I see that I think it was
last week, maybe five days ago, a bunch of
articles popped up about Hunter Biden's emails
again and pictures or whatever.
I just don't get what the story is for me.
I mean, he's a guy who has struggled in his
life.
He's not only not the president, but unlike
with Trump, because Biden doesn't have his
his kids working for him.
Hunter's not involved in government.
So I just don't really know what the story
is other than just that his last name is Biden
and he's Joe Biden's son.
So that's why I've I've not covered that one.
Does that make
Speaker 5: sense?
I think people are complaining about the nepotism,
the fact that he was able to get certain jobs
or certain things through his dad being the
vice president.
And it would seem in the emails that have
been released that that's kind of being corroborated.
Now, of course, I'm a simpleton from Texas,
so I try to just get smarter people to talk
about these things for me to understand.
But I'm having a hard time seeing both sides
connect on this.
It seems that one is saying, look, he's a
drug addict, nothing more to the story.
And the other side is saying, hey, that's
not even the story.
The story is actually all of these other things
that he was able to do because his dad was
vice president.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think what makes
this tough is there's an attempt being made
to say that it's just like Ivanka, Don Jr.,
Eric and Kushner in terms of getting stuff
because his dad was vice president.
It it seems to me not even remotely equivalent.
I mean, Trump had his kids working for him.
Ivanka was sitting in for Trump once when
they were in.
Was it Japan or I don't even know Helsinki.
I don't remember when or sat in for the secretary
of state.
Like, I think that to some degree, if you're
the vice president's kid, there are going
to be opportunities for you to do things that
will be given to you.
And then there's a question as to whether
you do something inappropriate or not.
And we can sort of explore that.
It just seems to be on a different playing
field than what Trump was doing with his kids.
And the very people obsessed with Hunter said
nothing and don't even care about what was
going on with Kushner and Ivanka.
And so it seems a little bit hypocritical
to me.
I would say
Speaker 5: I can agree with
that sentiment.
What
about
the issues around safety and
the allegations of perjury?